any practice of medicine and research in
the tropics requires a new examination
into the cause and nature of disease and
in terms of treatment a different
concept regarding the indigenous people
and the application of medicine to their
specific needs more often than not the
freshly recruited medical worker learns
that he must re-examine the relations
between people and the relations to
their environment that he had grown to
accept as constants the climate in all
its aspects creates conditions often
completely different from those known to
the uninitiated worker the important
issue of malnutrition and its direct and
indirect relationships to disease may
lead him to an analysis of agricultural
problems the way of life of the
indigenous people may be so foreign to
him that he must virtually become
psychologists anthropologists and social
workers on the other hand the prevalence
of insect born parasitic diseases makes
imperative a knowledge of the basic
biological sciences thus any study of
tropical medicine must be prefaced by an
emphasis on both the ecological nature
of the region and the way of life of the
people in this instance we will examine
the practice of medicine and medical
research in the Republic of Liberia
Liberia lies in the tropics on on the
west coast of Africa stretching from a
point 280 miles north of the equator
to a point 650 miles north the land
level rises from the coastline to 4,000
feet in the mountain foothills
some 150 miles inland
Liberia has been aptly characterized as
a watershed area the annual rainfall
ranges from a maximum of 200 inches
along the coast to 70 inches up country
the numerous rivers and their
tributaries overflow during the rainy
season when the temperature will fall to
a low of 50 degrees the annual mean
maximum temperature is 86 degrees the
mean minimum is 71 degrees and the
average annual humidity is 82% in the
dry season when the Harmattan winds read
in the sky with the sands of the North
African deserts the shade temperature
rises to the high 90s under these
conditions mycotic infections of the
skin are highly prevalent most of
Liberia was originally covered by
tropical rainforests large areas have
been cut over to meet the needs of a
primitive agriculture yet the resultant
sporadic cultivation has allowed second
growth forests to repossess the land the
temperature range and high humidity are
determinant factors in the development
of insect vectors of disease on the
other hand the life economy of some
insect species is such an intricate
complex of physiological requirements
that any slight environmental change can
upset the delicate equilibrium on which
survival depends such are the risks
attending extreme specialization as is
the case for the female sexy fly in the
reproductive cycle the most specific of
conditions are required a permanent
stream of water a sandy Bank into which
she inserts the larvae a barely constant
temperature and a low canopy of
vegetation producing nearly 100%
humidity in those areas of Liberia where
the heavy jungle growth has been
replaced by commercially productive
rubber trees with their high branches
and thin foliage the sexy fly has
disappeared many of the people's daily
functions of survival constitute
mechanisms by which they are exposed to
city confectioner a single body of water
is often the village's source for fish
bathing and drinking
thus they come in contact with many of
the insect and snail vectors
life in Africa may appear to be
lackadaisical to foreign eyes much
infection seems due to an absence of
precaution and a lack of interest in
bettering their lives but the land and
the climate are determinant factors
conditioning concepts of Hygiene life is
far from easy not to be plucked from the
nearest dream
the currents keep the fish away from
Liberia's coasts and often a successful
catch is made no closer than 80 miles
offshore the torrential rainfall in the
wet season leeches the soil in the high
soil temperature and the photo periodic
constancy 12 hours night and 12 hours
day curtail the growth of most grains
and vegetables that come from cooler
climates when rice and cassava are to be
planted the heavy forest must be cut
down without fertilization each crop of
rice exhausts the already weakened soil
as it must lie fallow for six years new
jungle areas must be cleared then at the
end of the six year period the original
plot is covered with scrum the cycle
begins anew and the laborious cutting
back of the jungle never ceases the
dearth of protein is compounded by the
unsuitability of the soil to support
forage crops and the presence of various
livestock diseases including
trypanosomiasis with arrow or gun the
hunter finds little success or as small
as the librarian population is it has
grown beyond the limit of its
diminishing forests to support wild game
with this limited diet the shortage of
protein and the mother's insufficient
supply of milk
the child's defense against infection is
critically impressive and no matter how
greatly we may admire the skill of the
metal craftsmen
long and tedious hours of labour are
required to fashion the most simple
implements and objects a division of
labor is obvious and clearly defined but
both sexes find the fruits of their
labor minimal and uncertain in such
primitive societies superstition exists
to conjure up answers to daily and
seasonal mysteries in place of
procedures born of an orderly appraisal
of data the necessary understanding of
nature is absent because there is no
knowledge of the cause of disease the
full disposal of sewage beyond the
limits of water source contamination is
not practiced because rivers are
everywhere accessible wells are seldom
sunk in the unobjective terms of what is
observable conclusions have been drawn
that well water is stale in a noble
attempt to relate tropical
cause-and-effect it is often believed
that the degree of coldness of well
water is the cause of colds thus the
existence of superstition is not due to
an unwillingness to learn and our
parting with ancient ways begins when
the process and the result become
predictable until generations of
individuals have learned from experience
the mystical authority of the
witchdoctor will prevail clay will
continue to be used as both a cosmetic
and a skin ointment disease will Fester
in isolation until it is sought out and
no matter how friendly is the image of
the friendly devil dancer he will for
some time continue to represent the
equation between primitive man's lack of
knowledge and nature's apparent Caprice
like behavior
against this background of primal need
research and medical organizations and
agencies are at work in Liberia scraping
away the surface of myth building a new
on the solid ground of need an objective
understanding of scientific process
emanating from the government of Liberia
and led by its energetic president the
Honorable William BS Tubman there exists
a program of ever-increasing medical
facilities and public health projects
the National Public Health Services
under the direction of dr. J in toga
provides and operates hospitals
dispensaries and conducts training
programs for nurses technicians and
sanitarians as this trained force grows
and the resultant education creates a
new demand for modern medicine an
increasing number of Liberian students
will take up the study of medicine in
the schools of Europe and America the
endeavor of the National Public Health
Services is furthered through
cooperation with various international
agencies in cooperation with the World
Health Organization they have
inaugurated a campaign to eliminate
malaria and yours and with the United
States international cooperation
administration they are conducting a
program of technical training in
addition to an anti malaria campaign
among the first medical efforts in
Liberia were those of the various
denominational missions in the almost
completely isolated villages long before
the penetration of roads they set up
their hospitals and dispensaries and the
personal histories of these medical
pioneers constitute a saga of men's
faith ingenuity and unfaltering energy a
saga seldom equal in the history of
human dedication
operating on another level of motive are
the two large commercial operations in
Liberia the Firestone plantations
company has been growing and processing
rubber since 1926
in recent years the Liberian mining
company has found success in the
extraction of high-grade iron ore these
two companies employ close to 30,000
Liberians and provide them and their
families with housing community and
medical facilities such medical programs
extend beyond the direct results of
treating and immunizing the employees
and their families viewed only
negatively an epidemic among this labor
force could cause havoc to the economy
of the country but as the first step
lies in the protection of the body of
men
and even more emphatic contribution is
born in the mind of men they are
operating the vehicles and machine tools
of the industrial world they are
learning the agricultural science of
plant breeding and grafting and they are
maintaining the chemistry of rubber
processing it is this skilled labor
force that represents the population
that is Liberia's future analyzed
positively in the light of these
occupational developments the Liberians
increasing dependence on and knowledge
of the world of medicine becomes an
attendant factor in liberius social and
economic growth serving as the fulcrum
of health and sanitation of the
Firestone plantations to hospitals
maintained over 200 beds staffed by
eleven physicians and 75 nurses lab
technicians and orderlies due to the
high level of mechanization in the
mining process and the consequently
limited labour force the Bomi Hills
hospital is smaller but its facilities
and services are equal to the best to be
found in Africa Bomi is especially
plagued with a heavily salted water
supply and as a check on its modern
filtration system a bacterial count is
maintained at all major distributive
points in both operations prevention
takes precedence over treatment
sanitation and hygiene in the company
villages constitute the basis of
prevention but the education and
vigilance of the villagers themselves is
a prerequisite to that goal
under the guidance of directives
developed by the medical staff each of
the plantation villages possesses a
train sanitarium who is periodically
checked and upgraded through
examinations the sanitarian maintains a
continuity in the method and
effectiveness of sewage disposal and in
general is custodian to the health needs
of his community the new pattern of
symmetrically designed villages takes
hold with the residents seeing the
benefits of drainages planned and
maintained thoroughfares and recreation
areas they also come to accept new and
improved types of housing that radically
depart from the traditional and
inadequate Hut
as the changing seasons bring changes in
the density and species of insect
vectors insecticide spraying teams move
through the villages and even with new
residents who have had little experience
with medicine and no knowledge of the
relationship between insect vectors and
disease the very elimination of the
pests from the houses represents a
newfound peace
thus the fullest performance of these
medical programs is obtained by bringing
prevention and treatment to the local
working and living areas in addition to
maintaining nurses at the hiring centers
and clinics in the heavily populated
factory area the plantation doctors
conduct regular frequent clinics at 36
dispensaries strategically located
across the 100,000 acres of the
plantation with such a program illness
is identified early guidance in the diet
and care of the newborn is provided and
the people learned that the practice of
modern medicine is a methodical
procedure composed of objective
knowledge and requiring only their
understanding and cooperation they learn
that the results of modern medicine tend
to be orderly and stable and nonviolent
and none dramatic in contrast to the
life-or-death prescription of the
country medicine man basic - all this
activity on both the public and private
level is research in that singular
interest the Liberian Institute of the
American Foundation for Tropical
Medicine was in 1946 incorporated in the
state of New York as a private nonprofit
organization in 1951 on a land grant
from
government of Liberia the present
structures were completed with funds
provided by Harvey s Firestone jr. as a
memorial to his father supported the
Institute comes from annual gifts made
by American business corporations
operating in the various tropical areas
including Liberia and by research grant
funds provided by the United States
Public Health Service the Institute's
basic goal is to contribute to the more
successful prevention and treatment of
tropical disease in such terms it has
successfully endeavored to fulfill a
four point program
attracted to this opportunity from all
over the world scientists study the
insect vectors and methods of control
while an outpatient clinic is maintained
by the Institute the nearby plantation
hospital sets aside beds or Institute
key studies requiring hospitalization
numerous villages serve as laboratories
of treatment and control and throughout
Liberia the Institute carries out
collaborative projects with such groups
as American universities
the World Health Organization and the
United States Public Health Service in
view of the variety and density of
tropical disease all of Liberia is
available for medical study
neural leprosy has two manifestations
Makakilo anesthetic leprosy a deep
pigmentation of skin patches and
utilization with loss of digits
nodular leprosy is often referred to as
lyin face
in Liberia there are several lapras area
supported by the National Public Health
Services and various missions here at
the Gunter Methodist mission under the
direction of dr. George W Harley the
discharge rate has been greatly
accelerated with the use of the new
therapeutic agents the incidence of
leprosy in Liberia is not known until
more extensive studies are carried out
there can be no certainty of existing
data while the few agencies in this
field are contributing a valuable
service the impression must remain that
no progress in control
eight however the cooperative reaction
of the patients their obvious desire for
the drugs and the attendant growth of an
interest in an understanding of disease
reveals that given data and facilities
the disease can be eradicated
yours is widely prevalent among the
Liberian population in the early stages
it is essentially a disease of the skin
later it becomes systemic and the most
troublesome lately shion's are those of
the bones joints and plantar surfaces of
the feet Gundu a nexus ptosis of the
facial bones it is considered by most
authorities to be a tertiary lesion of
yours plantar or crab yours this
condition which is characterized by the
development of tapa LaMotta under the
thick skin of the sole is very painful
eventually the overlying skin breaks
down and ulcers formed because it is
highly contagious the disease is one of
the most difficult to eradicate
and the incapacitating degree of pain
causes a heavy loss to the manpower of
the country osteitis results in saber
shins and deformities of the arms and
fingers collaborative projects on the
treatment of yours are being conducted
by the National Public Health Services
of Liberia the World Health Organization
and the United Nations International
Children's emergency fund
the filarial worm is transmitted by a
species of fly of the genus ammonium
commonly called the black fly which
breeds in rapidly flowing streams
infection causes unco circle dermatitis
shown here with a superimposed pyogenic
infection
and fibrous modules and in some
instances aya lesions here a nodule and
the pelvic region is being removed
on Kosar kosis is now considered by the
World Health Organization to be among
the most urgent medical problems in
Africa
bencroft Stella rias's is due to a
filarial worm parasite moocher area
Bancroft eye which invades the lymphatic
system it is transmitted by a number of
mosquito species very prevalent in
Liberia it is this parasite that gives
rise to elephantiasis also lymphangitis
a tinnitus and other clinical conditions
without the aid of a survey which would
be difficult the problems of TB is not
known it is recognized as widespread in
Liberia as in most underdeveloped
countries isolation hospitals are
provided by the National Public Health
Services utilising specific kemell
therapy the well known tendency of the
African to develop keloid growths is
well exemplified here
part of the growth was surgically
removed and it can be seen as recurring
around the edges of the excision einem
is a disease characterized by
spontaneous amputation of the fifth and
occasionally the fourth toe it is
brought about by constricting fibrous
bands developing at the base of the toes
the disease is most prevalent in West
Africa and Brazil the cause is unknown
ulcerative processes of the skin
especially on the legs are very common
and in some instances difficult to cure
African sleeping sickness is caused by
the protozoan parasite Trypanosoma at
Gambian Z which is transmitted by the
tsetse fly glossina propolis in its late
stages the disease is characterized by
disorders of the central nervous system
usually resulting in lethargy and a
stupor as' condition however the hyper
reactivity shown by this patient can
also occur
smallpox has recurred in Liberia
periodically in devastating epidemics
although there has been some
vaccinations the entire population is by
no means protected until there is 100%
vaccination the threat of the recurrence
exists the research work of the Liberian
Institute of the American Foundation for
Tropical Medicine extends beyond its 15
labs lab animal houses and workshops all
Liberia is its laboratory librarians
eager to improve their country strengths
take their own individual first step and
train as technicians as the scientist
possesses two methods of control where a
carrier is involved to destroy the
transmitting vector and to treat and
prevent the effects of the parasite in
the host so too does he depend on the
problem being attacked on more than one
front the basic conditions that weaken
the body and cause susceptibility must
also be eradicated
the Institute recognizes that one
problem basic to treatment is the
malnutrition of the people a lack of
protein in the diet to help combat this
scarcity the Liberian government the
United States International Cooperation
administration and Firestone are
establishing fish ponds
the creation of such a supply of protein
for each inland village is the final
goal with Liberia's climate ideally
suited for tree crops it is only natural
that the work of the many rubber coffee
and cocoa botanists is leaving a deep
mark taking advantage of this profound
cultural wedge an ICA agronomist shows a
tribal chief the increased resistance
and productivity of a new variety of
palm nut tree the oil of which is an
important food source the move is on to
educate a change from the growing of dry
rice to the less toilsome and higher
yielding swamp rice and the growing
presence on the plantation and
demonstration farms of mechanical tools
is producing an interest which promises
far-reaching results
on the medical side of Health by drug
and surgery the stories of scientific
treatment emanate from the plantation
hospitals to display a folklore of magic
at a Oh spellbinding with its facets of
sleep producing aromas
painless incisions
and quick recovery
with such an enviable social position
the physician gains an opportunity to
begin at the beginning and the expectant
mothers look forward to the scheduled
prenatal clinics
but to the continued progress of this
activity research is always fundamental
in the malarial work of the Liberian
Institute a complete knowledge of the
life habits of mosquito vectors and
their relation to malaria is an
essential prerequisite to the
establishment of a control program in
the laboratory thousands upon thousands
of mosquitoes are annually reared and
used in a variety of studies including
experimental infections and the
determination of the genetic factors in
acquired tolerance to insecticides to
determine the fluctuations in species
population and density throughout the
year collecting trips are made daily to
numerous localities over extended
periods to attract and capture the
mosquitoes teams of collectors set up
portable Hut traps in which they spend
rather fitful nights
you
by their growing understanding of the
methodology of science these technicians
gain some added strength and resisting
the normal desire to swat the little
pests
schistosomiasis or bilkul is prevalent
in large areas of Liberia Institute
surveys have shown close to 100%
infection in some regions the two
species of schistosomiasis and sunny are
carried by snails work is in progress to
test methods of destroying the snail
vectors and to determine the effects of
various drugs on the parasite across
country at the mines an Institute staff
member examines a group of children for
enlargement of the spleen to determine
the effectiveness of a residual
insecticide spraying program in the
eradication of the insect carrier
incidentally umbilical hernias such as
this one are very common among African
children however a large proportion of
the incidence disappears in adult life
trypanosomiasis sleeping sickness is
another disease prevalent in Liberia the
incidence however is not known on a tour
up country the Institute's director dr.
max Miller pays a visit to the clan
chief of a group of villages to secure
his cooperation and permission
in locating cases of the disease old
acquaintances exchange gossip news of
local crop conditions traded for a
report on a local youngster working as
an Institute technician then with the
ease of established trust the chief
leads the doctor to a nearby case and
the excited retinue eager for a
demonstration follows African sleeping
sickness
is a disease of major importance to the
health of Liberia the Institute's work
at the present time is mainly restricted
to the testing of drugs and a limited
surveying of the incidence of infection
as additional funds become available
research can be extended to a degree
commensurate with the need this case is
an advanced one the stage of infection
is demonstrated by extreme lethargy
walks only with the greatest difficulty
and assistance if left alone he would
show no interest in food and die of
starvation the extreme emaciation
obviously reveals that the case is
rapidly progressing to the last stages
because he is unable to perform the most
elementary personal hygiene he is
covered with a skin infection and is
irritable when disturbed
an experiment in administering a
malarial drug and the consequent blood
surveys moves into its ninth month two
groups of villages serve the
investigation all the population of one
half the villages have been given
monthly suppressive doses of anti
malarial drugs while the population of
the other half have taken placebos sugar
pills at the time of drug administration
a survey is made to determine the
malaria parasite rate in the entire
population group in the light of the
growing interdependence of Nations the
necessary trading of energy for skills
skills for resources and resources for a
participation in all the wealth of man's
achievement there can be seen a kinship
between the smallest most unconscious
endeavor and the greatest need
although the success of the survey is
dependent on the village receiving the
suppressives it is no less indebted to
the people taking placebos
if the development of backward areas has
become fundamental to the growing needs
of all people the eradication of
tropical disease lies in the category of
first things first as evidence of the
Liberian Institute's function facility
and opportunity to this end scientists
from all over the world are drawn to it
they work in a country that is friendly
to our concept of human dignity for the
Institute's very existence provides the
example of American business abroad
contributing to the health of man by its
ready acceptance of change when the
benefits are clear the population
reveals its desire to progress and the
government too is anxious to make a
dynamic contribution because it
recognizes that it cannot increase its
voice among the nations by only clipping
the coupons of the country's growing
wealth with this wealth of opportunity
and cooperation it is easy to see the
pattern necessary in the development of
the backward areas
there is a great prevalence of disease
an absence of proper foods and a lack of
knowledge concerning the realities of
the world that people live in cure the
disease
free the people for productive
enterprise and the indigenous people
will eagerly seek the knowledge
necessary to further enrich their lives
the Liberian Institute's dedication to
seek an expensive methods of treatment
and prevention attacks the core of the
problem to this end the Institute should
receive widespread support with the new
intercourse of trade the dark continents
resources of soil and climate are only
available as the health of the people is
secured in point of fact the health of
the world can benefit by so small so
unknowing a contribution as that being
made by the Liberian people in both the
test village and the control village in
one of the blood samples held against
the African light the image of all the
world's well-being can be seen